The all-star cast of Mamma Mia is back for
more sun sea and ABBA songs!
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here and
today I'm talking about the very best and
the not-so-great bits of the Mamma Mia sequel
and comparing it to the original movie so
obviously I'll be discussing spoilers.
By the way keep watching for details of my
very special Mamma Mia giveaway.
Because Mamma Mia 2 is both a prequel and
a sequel we get lots of new actors joining
the original cast and they're all really great.
A particular standout is Lily James who plays
the young Donna.
She really has tons of energy and spirit in
the role, a great voice, really gives her
all in the dance routines and works brilliantly
with all the new actors playing the younger
versions of her friends and lovers.
Then there's also Jeremy Irvine who plays
the young salmon he is just fantastic in the
role.
Now when I first heard that he'd been cast
as the young Pierce Brosnan character I wondered
why he hadn't been cast as the young version
of Colin Firth's character Harry instead.
Because he's done that before very well in
a film called The Railway Man.
But as a young Sam in Mamma Mia 2, Irvine
really does do an incredible take on a young
Pierce Brosnan.
Hugh Skinner and Josh Dylan are also great
as the young Harry and Bill.
Also new to the cast is Maria Vacratsis who
plays Sofia who gets some little scene stealing
moments especially a short scene that she
has with the young Sam which I thought was
just perfect.
Also just brilliant in this film is the actress
who plays young Tanya and she's called Jessica
Keenan Wynn.
She absolutely perfectly channels the spirit
of Christine Baranski's Tanya.
Again like Jeremy Irving with Pierce Brosnan
she's not doing an impression of Christine
Baranski but she's taking those aspects a
little idiosyncrasies in the way she speaks
her cadence and things, taking some of them
putting them into the younger role of Tanya
but also bringing other things apart as well.
Young Rosie who's played by Alexa Davies also
brings some nice little moments as
well so you can really look forward to seeing
those two on screen.
And the moment where young Tanya tells young
Sam that she visually enjoys him is just priceless.
As for the returning cast I cannot get enough
of Christine Baranski and Julie Walters as
Donna's friends and fellow dynamos Tanya and
Rosie.
"The beauty comes not only from the exquisite
structure of your bones and your laughter
and your sparkling eyes but from the goodness
that flowers within you like a fountain."
"Have him washed and brought to my tent."
"I don't think fountains flower, did they?"
"Mine does."
And then there's a hilarious way they sing
Angel Eyes to Sophie with Christine Baranski's
Tanya hardly letting Judy Walters' Rosie get
a word in edgeways.
Of course the prequel aspect of this film
means there are obviously fewer scenes with
the original cast which of course is a bit
of a shame because they're all so great.
So for example while we do see Colin Firth,
Stellan Skarsgard and Pierce Brosnan sing,
dance and act, we do see them doing less of
that than we did in the first film.
Speaking of the original cast, someone I would
have loved have seen much more of is Meryl
Streep as Donna.
I just adored scenes Streep singing, dancing
and acting with gusto in the first film and
I really did miss her here.
Now while we certainly don't get enough Meryl
Streep in the movie we do get the added benefit
of Cher in a role that was written specifically
for her and which fits her like a glittery
glove.
Is it a touch insane that Cher who's only
three years older than Meryl Streep in real
life is playing Donna's mother?
Of course it is!
Do I care?
Absolutely not.
Because at the end of the day we get to hear
Cher sing Fernando complete with a big fireworks
display and we get some crazy moments with
Sophie's grandma.
Now when it comes to the music obviously in
the first film we got an absolute ton of Abbas
biggest greatest hits which means that in
this film we get some lesser-known Abba tracks
like When I Kissed The Teacher, Why Did It
Have To Be Me, Kisses Of Fire and Andaunte,
Andante, I've Been Waiting For You and My
Love, My Life.
But we do also get some songs that weren't
in the original film that you will - I think
- definitely recognize.
There's The Name Of The Game which is performed
by Lily James.
There's Knowing Me, Knowing You which is again
Lily James and Jeremy Irvine and there's also
Angel Eyes and Fernando as well and not to
worry because we do still get many of the
hugely popular hits from the first film.
So there's Mamma Mia, Dancing Queen, Super
Trouper and Waterloo to name a few.
For Dancing Queen we get a flotilla of fishermen
along with Stellan Skarsgard and Colin Firth
recreating the Titanic pose as they sailed
towards the island.
And for Waterloo it's in a Parisian restaurant
with a young Harry and Donna and we even get
an Abba cameo as well with Benny playing the
piano.
And Mamma Mia gets a spirited performance
by the Young Dynamos this time when the film
proper ends we get a fantastic version of
Super Trouper with all the main cast joining
in.
While Super Trouper was amazing I was a little
bit disappointed that we only got one song
and dance routine in the kind of curtain call
cast party moment in the film this time around
'cos last time if you remember we got two
songs.
We got Dancing Queen and Waterloo so it would
have been fantastic if we just got one more.
Now if you stay to the very end of the credits
after everyone's names rolled by we do get
a little unexpected extra something.
There's an unexpected post-credits scene which
makes up a little bit for only one extra song
after the film finishes.
The post credits scene features comic actor
Omid Djalili as the Greek official who was
checking people's passports before they boarded
the island ferry earlier in the film.
If you remember he had quite a few opinions
about what people look like in their passport
photos compared to real life and usually told
them they look better in the photo except
in the case of Colin Firth's Harry who he
said looked great and had aged like a fine
wine.
If you missed the post-credits scene it basically
shows a young Harry has followed Donna to
Greece where the Greek official tells him
if she rejects you give me a call.
Then he follows up his proposition by singing
a few lines from Take A Chance On Me.
Overall then while there are some more melancholy
and wistful moments in this film compared
to the first there's still a boatload of joyous
effervescent scenes overflowing with great
song and dance routines.
And though it's not quite the non-stop charmer
the original was, my my, how could I resist
it?
So yes I did thoroughly enjoy Mamma Mia 2
and will definitely be watching it again hopefully
soon.
Now how do you think the Mamma Mia sequel
compares to the first film?
And what are your favorite moments or songs
in the new movie?
If you want to take a chance on winning one
of these awesome Mamma Mia 2 merch packs,
make sure you subscribe and leave me a comment
about the film, and also tap the Gleam link
in the video description below to register
your entry.
I've got new Mamma Mia videos coming up, so
tap left to watch the next one or tap right
for my full Mamma Mia playlist.
If you liked this, I really appreciate a thumbs-up!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!